Film Courage: Why do you say
the more people dislike the
antagonist the more they'll
get involved in the story?
Writer/Professor Jeffrey Davis: I don't
agree with that, so go ahead. I think
that's a little…I don't know if we said that
in the book, did we? I think that's too simple.
Writer/Professor/Psychologist Peter Desberg:
Well let's put it this way, think of it as you
have we talked about two basic factors you got
your conflict you got your character now Within
conflict you have an antagonist who's going to
provide a big source of your conflict and then
you've got your protagonist who's going to fight
against it the bigger the the the bigger the
conflict well how are you going to raise the
conflict one of the easiest ways is you have
a better and better antagonist if the person
is clever ruthless creative it's a much more
interesting antagonist than big teeth and a lot
of saliva right but but again if you if you want
to make the the conflict look insurmountable and
I mean it could be a fire breathing monster or it
could be a professor who is not going to let you
get your degree because your work was too close to
his doesn't matter they can be equally diabolical
yeah and the more bad traits you give them person
the the more bad things that person is willing
to do the bigger your conflict is going to be and
again it could be very obvious ruthless things or
it could be very very subtle things and sometimes
the subtler things are more Insidious because
nobody sees them but it's still the the worse
your antagonist is the more you can raise the
stakes the more you can make the conflict bigger.
Jeffrey: I'm going to go back to Die Hard because
I still think it's the best movie in that genre.
He was a great antagonist and what made him great
well two things one it was brilliantly the accent,
brilliantly written it's all the accent. Well the
thing about Alan Rickman is he was a Shakespeare
trained British actor and done state I can almost
tell in actor who's worked on the stage from one
who's never worked on the stage but what they
wrote Steven de Souza what he did which really
interesting is that he made the antagonist
as interesting if not more interesting than
the Bruce Willis’s character and there's a twist
you think that they're terrorists if you remember
the movie you think they're terrorists everybody
else thinks thinks they're terrorists but they're
really just Crooks Crooks and the Bonnie
bedelia's line in the movie is you're just
kind common thieves and he says and it's right at
the top of the third act he says there is nothing
common about me Madam or something I mean and
he had the Thousand suit the Armani th and you
understood him see that's the that's the trap in
villains is if you don't understand the villain
and you don't care a little bit about how crazy
and evil they are I don't think there's a movie
and the thing that I also love about about that
movie is he was playing a psychological game with
Bruce Willis's character and that's the danger
in writing and I say this this is about writing
scripts not and novels or plays or anything the
danger is to not make the antagonist which is what
I prefer to call them more more interesting than
your protagonist which a lot of people will do in
the early drafts because protagonists are harder
to write flaws into because that's the character
typically the writer identifies with right but I
I don't think that antagonist yes I mean I think
calling them just a villain limits an act because
I do a lot of talking now about and I think it's
really important for writers to understand what's
playable in a scene and what's not so actors will
always say that how am I going you say she's angry
that's not a playable thing how is she angry how
is she expressing that anger then then an actor
can start looking into because they want to give
that especially today with all this great stuff
being written they want to do they want to really
go into and find a way into those characters this
thing is really interesting that I told you about
gaslit the guy he's a very famous character actor
I can't think of his name but he's playing Gordon
Liddy probably one of the most evil people that
ever walked to the face of the earth and I saw an
interview with him and he said the script allowed
me a way in and the way in was his feelings for
his family so he wasn't he I mean the guy was
loved Adolf Hitler there were all kinds of things
about the real Gordon Liddy that are just he was
in too but he loved his family and that's the way
the actor went in writers have to think about that
when they're writing they can't just write like a
kind of a stick figure character and say a lot
of writers I know and they're starting they'll
go well the actor will fill that in now you good
luck getting an actor to play the role and when
you get to be a little bit more experienced you
start thinking about the the other people who are
get involved in this collaborative experiment
that you do when you're on a show or a film is
like it's not just about you it's about everybody
you know the interior exterior stuff and scripts I
don't think a lot of people realize that the last
person that matters to is the writer the writer
puts that in there for the set designer for the
cost all those things are done for other people
and I don't think that's taught it's not no it's
not just a thing to do what would we need it we
know the script we need to know if it's interior
or exterior we need to know how many what are the
costumes what that's why you don't write too
much you don't do other people's jobs for them
but you help them to maybe see the world that was
what William Goldman always said and I think it's
great. Don't design costumes and don't cast the
movie like what I always have to tell students
is don't say “he's 40.” First of all what does
40 look like? And second of all casting records
will get so angry with you “A white man who's
40.” What does that even mean? So imagination…
Peter: But I think you want to be
careful about making a generalization.
Jeffrey: Never make a generalization!
Peter: …About the nature of an antagonist right
because there are some antagonists who were just
bad from the beginning yeah everything about them
is bad and you hate everything they do and they're
really obviously evil terrible people. That has
the risk of being cartoony but it can also just
be such an evil person, when you have Hitler as
your antagonist that's a pretty good antagonist,
not such a nice guy at least so I've heard
but sometimes it's the guy that you don't
even realize as the antagonist until way later
who's done things so subtly and so small and so
insidious that everybody's wondering why these
terrible things are happening and nobody can
identify the source and every point in between.
So I think it's a decision you make about the
kind of script you're writing and if it's a
war movie Hitler is more interesting if it's
somebody who really wants want a degree
and she's never returned to Professor's
favors and can't get the degree by it's a whole
different thing and it can be just as insidious.
Jeffrey: Yeah, that doesn't really contradict
anything I'm saying. I'm just saying.
Peter: I didn’t say it did. It does but…
Jeffrey: I know. Just don't punch
because I'm a very delicate flower.
Jeffrey: All I am saying is no matter what you do,
dimensional dimensionalize this is one of
the reasons that I'm not a fan of superhero
movies except with a few exceptions
the Robert Downey ones are great.
Peter: But I'm thinking the way you asked the
question made it sound like well the more the
more horrible and I don't think that's necessarily
true right and it's it's the subtlety the guile
with which it's done the intensity I mean if you
think of all the different dimensions you can be
bad on it's a lot of dimensions I had there
was a a very very famous psychologist named
Albert Ellis who I had the the great opportunity
to spend a week doing a practicum with him and he
did a interesting thing where he said here's a
desk can you measure it and everybody said yeah
that's easy he just take take a tape measure no
that's measuring its length I want you to measure
the desk say well what do you mean so well how
many ways can you measure a desk well you could
also do its weight you could do its height you
could do the material it's made of you can do
the cache value of it its age its antique value
it's how many dimensions can you measure and it
starts to become near infinite and then say now
let's measure a person and when you start seeing
all the possible dimensions you have to play with
and then there's an interesting phenomenon in the
psychology of problem solving that when the
dimension that you're looking for to solve a
problem is the salient dimension it's very easy
to solve the problem when it's not salient it's
very difficult so I would do a demonstration
with students where I'd say I’d point to a
black student and I point to a white student say
okay the question is what's the difference between
these students and they'd say well one is black
one is white easy because that's the first thing
you notice about them I do with an old person a
young person easy now I'd give them another one
where I'm looking at are they wearing tennis
shoes or leather shoes what's the difference
between these people and there guessing all sorts
of crap and they don't get anywhere close to the
problem because the dimension wasn't salient
it wasn't a dimension you'd see easily so if
you think about using that in your script and you
start to say let's not take the obvious thing how
bad is your super weapon and rather how what's the
subtle power you have to stop this person all of a
sudden it becomes a totally different script and
it can be diabolic or than the other way of going
about doing it so you asked a you asked a very
profound question she's good at that I have one
thing to add I don't want to forget this because
it's in the book and almost everybody told us this
and I think this is a relatively new thing that
people didn't ask 20 years ago and Peter reminded
me of it when he was just talking about degrees
of evil and stuff see it's my fault actually it's
good thing you're going to be you're if you're not
asked they're not doing their job the question I
have when somebody pitches is why you why now
so I think I think it's like if you whether
you bringing somebody an idea for a product if
you're going to an entrepreneur whatever it's
like why are you the person to do this why are
you the person to write this script why are you
the person to do this miniseries and it doesn't
it's not autobiographical I have a friend who's
doing a a miniseries about a historical princess
that nobody knows anything about and and it's a
fascinating story she's been researching this
person for 10 years so that's something you
would say in a pitch, I think the more commitment
they see from you the more they see that you care
the more they'll care I mean because anybody can
pitch a story about some vague thing out there
so one of the things I think when he's talk when
Peter's talking about degrees I think you come up
with a villain if you want to call them a villain
or an antagonist use yourself use your life don't
don't try to write from air I think that that
that's bad writing you've got to use yourself
who else do you have that doesn't mean you have
to write autobiography but we're all using ourself
no matter what we do and I think that's where
pictures very often go south is people see you
don't have a personal commit you don't have
the passion and I didn't want to let the day
go without bringing that in because it's really
I think that's a really important point and it
it might be why you're the person but you may not
have a personal direct connection with the to but
you can talk about your fascination with it and
why you got interested in it right so either way
but somehow one of the interesting points we kept
finding over and over again is transmitting your
enthusiasm for your project right if you're not
committed and they don't see you having passion
for it why should they and this is something that
you mention why did you write this and what aspect
of it got you so excited right so you could be
writing a caveman drama but if it's something
about I'm really interested in interpersonal
conflicts and where do they start when did
people go from I need to save my life do I need
to dominate you that's okay whatever it is but you
need to think about a rationale that was enough to
pull you in and get you excited and then your job
is to say how can I transmit this excitement
right to make somebody else curious right.